l'oci après la voyance la numérologie
voici à visage découvert et pour la
première fois la voie la plus célèbre de
la métérologie monsieur albert simon
comme j'aimerais également que notre
invite les spectateurs savent bien qu'il
s'agit d'albert ciment voulez vous le
dire bonsoir avec votre voix inimitable
et pensons à tout le monde
vous avez entendu la voyager pas très
bien entendu tout ce qu'elle a dit non
eh bien nous nous allons écouter
avidement ce que vous allez dire parce
que c'est là que nous devons savoir si
on peut vraiment parti au mois de
juillet en toute confiance
monsieur albert simon nous écoutions
comme nous l'avons fait depuis 27 ans
sur les ondes
je vous remercie beaucoup le beau temps
près votre en juillet ce sera à moi plus
ensoleillé que d'habitude avec au moins
trois pointes de fortes chaleurs de
courte durée il pleuvra moi pas de puits
continue mais des orages sur l'émotivité
l'arrière il fera le plus souvent sec et
très chaud jusqu'à 35 degrés en provence
à la mi-juillet 37 degrés dans le var le
29 date à laquelle le scirocco se fera
encore cette période de sécheresse sera
suivie de violents coups de mistral au
mois d'août
moi qui sera nettement moins chaud
conséquence à partir du 10 août des
incendies de garrigue et de forêts dans
les bouches-du-rhône et le var sur les
alpes ap un coup de froid furtif au
début de juillet le beau temps prévaudra
durant tout le mois de juillet et dans
le sud-ouest de grandes variations de
température des pyrénées en charente où
les pointes de chaleur se termineront
par de gros orages aux environs du 8 du
19 et 29 des orages aussi sur les pays
de loire le bassin parisien les régions
du centre la bourgogne la franche comté
les vosges et l'alsace
alors j'aimerais votre conclusion le
mois de juillet finalement au travers de
tout cela
un bon mois un bon mois et bien pour
nous ça a été un bon moment d'accueillir
monsieur albert ciment dans le visage
était resté inconnu pendant près de 25
ans et qu'il l'a ce soir révélée aux
téléspectateurs de fr3 je vous l'accordé
très fort merci tout va bien il avait
même amené son chapeau